Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is, therestishistory.com. No Frills delivers. Get groceries delivered to your door from No Frills with PC Express. Shop online and get $15 in PC Optimum Points on your first five orders. Shop now at NoFrills.ca. The Reverend Mr. Davidson's downfall was girls. Not a girl, not five or six girls even, not a hundred, but the entire tremulous universe
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、提前收听系列节目，并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。也就是说，therestishistory.com。No Frills 为您送货上门。通过 PC Express 从 No Frills 订购杂货并送货上门。网购并在前五个订单中获得 15 加元的 PC Optimum 积分。立即在 NoFrills.ca 购物。戴维森牧师（The Reverend Mr. Davidson）的堕落始于女孩。不是一个女孩，甚至不是五六个女孩，也不是一百个，而是整个令人悸动的
of girlhood. Shingled heads, clear cheeky eyes, nifty legs, warm blunt-fingered workaday hands, small, firm breasts, and, most importantly, good, strong, healthy teeth besotted him. A single human life was all too short for him to savour such a universe, and his awareness of this allowed him to encounter at least a thousand girls during the twenties alone. Quite early on in his sacred career, he hit upon an exciting solution to what otherwise might have been an insoluble problem.
少女世界。平头短发、清澈俏皮的眼睛、时髦的长腿、温暖粗钝的日常双手、紧致的小乳房，最重要的是，一口健康、洁白、强壮的好牙，让他神魂颠倒。短暂的人类一生实在太短，根本无法让他尽情品味这样一个世界，而这种意识让他仅在二十年代就结识了至少一千个女孩。在他的神圣生涯的早期，他就想出一个令人兴奋的解决方案，来应对这个原本可能无法解决的问题。
He would make girls his special ministry. And so he set about it with a single mindedness which in any other circumstances should have brought him a deanery. So that is from Ronald Blythe's book The Age of Illusion which is the history of Britain in the 1920s and 1930s. Ronald Blythe did not talk like that but I think the quality of the material is kind of appropriate to, I can imagine Alec Guinness or somebody maybe reading that out. And Dominic, it's a brilliantly funny witty book, isn't it? Full of strange stories and anecdotes. And you, like me, have fixed on
他决定让女孩们成为他的特殊宣教对象。于是，他以一种无论在什么情况下都本该为他赢得院长职务的专注精神投入其中。这段话摘自罗纳德·布莱思（Ronald Blythe）的书《幻觉时代》（The Age of Illusion），该书讲述了 20 世纪 20 年代和 30 年代的英国历史。罗纳德·布莱思说话并不那样，但我认为这种材料的品质很合适，我能想象出亚历克·吉尼斯（Alec Guinness）或某个人也许会把那段话读出来。多米尼克，这是一本极其有趣且机智的书，不是吗？充满了奇怪的故事和轶事。你和我一样，注意到了
one chapter in particular, which is the extraordinary story of Harold Davidson, who was the rector of church in a Norfolk village called either Stiffy or Stookey. And opinions on this vary and we will be coming to the big debate on how you pronounce that word in due course. People in Britain have always loved the kind of scandal hit Vicar and the rector of Stiff Guy or Stookey is the archetype of that, isn't he? He is the ultimate scandal played Vicar, as fair to say. So if listeners like the episode and they want to buy Ronald Bride's book, The Age of Illusion, the Folio Society edition has an introduction by me, which I did about 10 years ago. And when I was reading that book, this one chapter, I mean, it's all great, but this one chapter absolutely leapt out at me. He is an extraordinary man.
其中特别的一个章节，这是一个非凡的故事，主人公是诺福克一个名叫 Stiffy 或 Stookey 的村庄的教堂 rector（主任牧师）。人们对此看法不一，我们稍后将讨论关于如何发音这个词的大辩论。英国人一直都很喜欢那种卷入丑闻的牧师，而 Stiff Guy 或 Stookey 的主任牧师就是这种形象的原型，对吧？可以说，他就是终极的丑闻牧师。因此，如果听众喜欢这一集，并且想买罗纳德·布莱思的书《幻觉时代》（The Age of Illusion），《Folio Society》的版本里有一篇我大约 10 年前写的引言。当我读到那本书的那一章时，我的意思是，整本书都很棒，但唯独这一章深深地吸引了我。他是一个不寻常的人。
He is a man who boasted, who prided himself on, to use his own terminology, picking up 200 girls a year. He made newspaper headlines day after day in the mid 1930s. Having been a vicar of this small parish in Norfolk, he ended up as a fairground attraction in Europe's most popular seaside resort and he has a final showdown with a lion called Freddy before a gaping audience of holidaymakers in Skegness. So Tom it is an incredibly funny story but it's quite a melancholy story as well.
他是一个吹嘘、以……为傲的人，用他自己的术语来说，就是一年物色 200 个女孩。在 20 世纪 30 年代中期，他日复一日地成为报纸头条。在担任诺福克这个小教区的牧师之后，他最终成了欧洲最受欢迎的海滨度假胜地的一个游乐场景点，在斯凯格内斯（Skegness）目瞪口呆的度假者面前，他和一头名叫弗雷迪（Freddy）的狮子进行了最后的决战。所以，汤姆，这是一个非常搞笑的故事，但同时也是一个相当忧郁的故事。
Isn't it? You think it's quite a dark story. I do. Well, so I came across this story when I went to the place you described as Europe's most popular seaside resort, which is Blackpool. I read Ronald Blythe's chapter on the vicar of Stukie or Stifke there, and I've been wanting to do an episode on him ever since. And now at last we get the chance.
不是吗？你觉得这是一个相当黑暗的故事。我是这么认为的。嗯，我是在去了你所描述的欧洲最受欢迎的海滨度假胜地——也就是黑潭（Blackpool）——的时候偶然发现这个故事的。我在那里读了罗纳德·布莱思关于斯图基（Stukie）或斯蒂夫克（Stifke）牧师的那一章，从那以后我就一直想做一期关于他的节目。现在我们终于有机会了。
And it strikes me that actually coincidentally, this is quite an odd pairing with our previous episode, which was also about a priest from East Anglia behaving badly. And it featured a trial on an East Anglian offence that was done in London. So there were certain points of comparison. But just to put my cards on the table, I think the Reverend Mr. Davidson is not remotely as bad a person as Thomas of Monmouth, who featured in our previous episode. Indeed, I think he's maybe quite hard done by.
而且我发现，实际上巧合的是，这与我们之前的那集节目形成了相当奇怪的搭配，那集也是关于一个行为不端的东安格利亚（East Anglia）神父的。其中还讲述了一起在伦敦审理的东安格利亚罪行审判。所以存在某些可比之处。但坦白讲，我认为戴维森牧师远没有我们上一集中的蒙茅斯的托马斯（Thomas of Monmouth）那么坏。事实上，我认为他可能有点冤枉。
Yes, I may well agree with you. Now, anybody who thinks, gosh, this is a slight subject, you should stand corrected because no lesser historian than AP Taylor said that the story of the Reverend Mr. Davidson offered a great parable of the age of the interwar years in his, in his history of this period. He wrote of him, he attracted, he, the Reverend attracted more attention than say Cosmo Gordon Lang, Archbishop of Canterbury, which man deserves a
是的，我很可能同意你的看法。现在，任何觉得“天哪，这是一个无聊的主题”的人都应该纠正这种看法，因为不亚于历史学家 A·P·泰勒（A.P. Taylor）曾说过，在他关于这段时期的历史中，戴维森牧师的故事为两次世界大战之间的那个时代提供了一个伟大的寓言。他这样写道：他吸引了……他，这位牧师吸引了比坎特伯雷大主教科斯莫·戈登·朗（Cosmo Gordon Lang）还要多的关注，究竟哪个人更配得上
greater place in the history books. And I think our answer is quite clear because we will never do a podcast about cosmo lang i think i will do a whole series about harold davidson. Now he is attracted it's a sign of his importance that is attracted several excellent biographers most recently an author from norfolk with jonathan tuckett who wrote a book with the troublesome priest who argues who argues that like you Tom, he thinks Harold Davidson has been much maligned. So let's get into his story. He was born just outside Southampton in Hampshire in 1875 and he came from an ecclesiastical family. More than 20 of his relatives had been Anglican clergymen and his father Francis Davidson was the local vicar in this place called Schoeling in Hampshire. And another of Davidson's biographers, Tom Cullen, describes his father as a tiny man with a luxuriant beard that gave him the appearance of a gnome.
在历史书中占据更大的篇幅？我想我们的答案很清楚，因为我们永远不会做一个关于科斯莫·朗的播客，我想我会做一个关于哈罗德·戴维森（Harold Davidson）的系列节目。他吸引了……这表明他的重要性，他吸引了几位优秀的传记作家，最近的一位是来自诺福克的作家乔纳森·塔基特（Jonathan Tuckett），他写了一本名为《麻烦的牧师》（The Troublesome Priest）的书，他认为，就像你汤姆一样，他认为哈罗德·戴维森受到了很多恶意的诽谤。让我们来了解他的故事。他于 1875 年出生在汉普郡南安普顿郊外，出身于一个神职人员家庭。他的亲戚中有一二十人曾是英国国教的神职人员，他的父亲弗朗西斯·戴维森（Francis Davidson）是汉普郡一个叫肖林（Schoeling）的地方的当地牧师。戴维森的另一位传记作家汤姆·卡伦（Tom Cullen）将他的父亲描述为一个身材矮小、留着浓密胡须、外表看起来像个地精的人。
And his mother was the great niece of Dr. Arnold, as in Tom Brown and rugby school. So he's the great, great nephew of Dr. Arnold, which is quite a thought. Here's the point at which our podcasts on Benjamin Lay and Harry Potter and public schools meet I think it's fair to say because Harold Davidson was a very short man. He was five foot three. He went to a school called Whitgift in Croydon where actually I've been to give a talk. They have a very good history festival. I recommend it. He stayed with his maiden aunts in Croydon and under their influence,
他的母亲是阿诺德博士（Dr. Arnold）的侄孙女，就像《汤姆·布朗求学记》和拉格比学校里的那个阿诺德一样。所以他是阿诺德博士的玄孙，这真是一个令人惊叹的想法。这就是我们关于本杰明·莱（Benjamin Lay）、哈利·波特和公学（public schools）的播客交汇的地方，我认为这样说很公平，因为哈罗德·戴维森个子非常矮。他身高五尺三寸（约 160 厘米）。他去了一所名叫怀特吉夫（Whitgift）的学校，位于克罗顿（Croydon），实际上我去那里做过演讲。他们有一个非常好的历史节。我推荐它。他住在克罗顿的未婚阿姨家里，在她们的影响下，
they were massive kind of Christian do-gooders, under their influence, Harold worked part-time at Toynbee Hall in the East End, this kind of settlement house, helping the poor. I mean, that is the idea, isn't it, of the middle classes going out into darkest London. The idea that you bring poor relief, not just to darkest Africa, but to the most poverty-stricken reaches of the capital. And I guess it's really the kind of intersection point between institutional Christianity and socialism, massively influential. It is.
她们是那种典型的基督教慈善人士，在她们的影响下，哈罗德在东区（East End）的汤因比楼（Toynbee Hall）做兼职，这是一个类似于社会福利馆的机构，帮助穷人。我的意思是，这就是中产阶级深入伦敦最黑暗角落的理念，不是吗？这种理念不仅仅是将救济带到最黑暗的非洲，而是带到首都最贫困的角落。我想这确实是体制化的基督教和社会主义之间的交汇点，具有巨大的影响力。确实如此。
And actually there is a political dimension to Mr. Davidson's career, which we will come to. Now the expectation is that he will follow his father into the priesthood. But when he was at school, he discovered the pleasures of the stage. He acted in farces with his friend from school, who's a man called Leon Quatermain, who later became a West End star and actually acted with what became the Royal Shakespeare Company. So that's really good. And Davidson's life might well have been happier had he continued in that career, don't you
事实上，戴维森先生的职业生涯还有一个政治维度，我们待会儿会谈到。人们原本期望他子承父业，进入神职界。但当他还在上学时，他发现了舞台的乐趣。他与学校的朋友、后来成为西区（West End）明星并曾与后来的皇家莎士比亚剧团（Royal Shakespeare Company）合作的演员莱昂·夸特曼（Leon Quatermain）一起出演闹剧。这真的很棒。如果戴维森继续从事那个职业，他的人生可能会更幸福，你不
think? Oh, unquestionably, unquestionably. So actually, when he left school in 1894, his family expected him to go to Oxford and to study for Holy Orders, but he does something very different. He becomes an actor. So his specialism is the sort of classic late Victorian Edwardian light entertainment, drawing room comedies for the kind of respectable middle classes. And his finest hour, he played Lord Fancourt Babally in the fast Charlie's aunt. Which involves dressing up as a woman, doesn't it? Yes.
觉得吗？哦，毫无疑问，毫无疑问。所以实际上，他在 1894 年离开学校时，他的家人期望他去牛津大学学习并准备接受圣职，但他做了一件非常不同的事。他成了一名演员。所以他的专长是那种典型的维多利亚时代晚期至爱德华时代早期的轻娱乐，也就是针对正派中产阶级的客厅喜剧。他高光时刻是，在闹剧《查理的姑妈》（Charley's Aunt）中扮演了范库特·巴巴利勋爵（Lord Fancourt Babally）。这需要女扮男装，对吗？是的。
So he dresses up as his friend's aunt. This is the great joke of the play. Now the thing is while he's being in these vases, he's still quite a morally serious person. He's a teetotaler. And when they go to the provincial towns to do plays, he will give Bible readings to the elderly. You know, he takes this quite seriously.
所以他装扮成他朋友的姑妈。这是这部戏的一大笑点。现在的问题是，虽然他在这些闹剧中演出，但他仍然是一个在道德上相当严肃的人。他是一个禁酒主义者。当他们去外省城镇演戏时，他会给老人们朗读圣经。你知道的，他对此相当认真。
And in fact, in 1894, so at the end of the year, by his own account, he has an encounter that changes his life. He's walking along the embankment of the River Thames in London in heavy fog, and he comes across a girl of 16 who was about to throw herself into the river. And she is from Cambridge. She has run away from home, she has no money, and she has nowhere to go. And he takes pity on her. He offers to pay her fare home, and he gives her a letter to her mother explaining what
事实上，在 1894 年，也就是年底，根据他自己的说法，他经历了一次改变他一生的奇遇。当时伦敦正逢大雾，他正走在泰晤士河（River Thames）的河岸边，遇到了一位 16 岁的女孩，她正准备跳河自尽。她来自剑桥。她离家出走，身无分文，无处可去。他动了恻隐之心。他主动提出替她支付回家的车票，并写了一封信给她母亲，解释了他
he's done. And he said afterwards, her pitiful story made a tremendous impression on me. I have ever since kept my eyes open for opportunities to help that kind of girl. That kind of girl. Now, the trouble is. What do you mean by that? Yes, I've always kept my eyes open for opportunities to help girls like that. You can interpret that of course, two ways. And I think one of the things that listeners will have to decide for
所做的一切。他后来写道：“她那悲惨的身世给我留下了深刻的印象。从那以后，我一直留心寻找帮助这类女孩的机会。”“这类女孩”。现在，问题来了。你这话是什么意思？是的，我一直留心寻找帮助像那样的女孩的机会。当然，你可以从两个方面来解读这句话。我想，听众需要自行决定的事情之一，就是
themselves is whether to take a charitable explanation of his activities or a more cynical one. Anyway, four years after this, he decides he will give in to his father and he will become a vicar after all. His father has a friend called Basil Wilberforce, a descendant of the great man. And Basil Wilberforce is the chaplain to the Speaker of the House of Commons. And he says, Oh, I can wangle your boy a place in my old college, Exeter, Exeter College, Oxford, even though Harold doesn't have very good qualifications.
究竟是以慈善的眼光来看待他的活动，还是以更愤世嫉俗的眼光来看待。无论如何，四年后，他决定向父亲妥协，最终还是当了一名牧师。他父亲有个朋友叫巴索·威尔伯福斯（Basil Wilberforce），是大人物的后代。巴索·威尔伯福斯是下议院议长的牧师。他说：“哦，我可以托关系为你儿子在我当年的母校埃克塞特学院（Exeter College, Oxford）谋个位置，尽管哈罗德的成绩并不是很好。”
So he gets this place at Exeter, Oxford. He goes up there and he's useless. He doesn't really want to be there. He says he really wanted to be an actor. He says later, I could have earned hundreds of pounds a year as an actor, but I've had to settle for three pounds a week as a curate, which is not very much. He's still massively into the theatre. He's still appearing in plays.
于是他得到了牛津埃克塞特学院的名额。他去那儿读书，结果却一无所能。他其实并不想呆在那里。他说他真正想做的是演员。他后来谈到：“我当演员本可以一年赚几百英镑，但我却不得不满足于每周三英镑的助理牧师（curate）薪水，这实在是不多。”他依然对戏剧有着极大的热情。他仍然在参演戏剧。
And it was later said that he decorated his Oxford rooms with signed photographs of actresses, which perhaps not the ideal look if you're hoping to be a late Victorian man of the cloth. Anyway, he ignores the rules at Oxford. He's always late. He fails loads of exams. And in 1901, he's basically kicked out to a private hall associated with Oxford school Grindles hall, and it takes him two years to pass and the Bishop of and in 1901 he's basically kicked out to a private hall associated with Oxford called
后来有人说，他在牛津的房间里装饰着女演员们的签名照片，如果你希望成为一名维多利亚时代晚期的神职人员，这或许并不是最理想的形象。总之，他在牛津无视校规。他总是迟到。他挂了很多科。到了 1901 年，他基本上被赶到了一家与牛津有关的私立大厅——格林德尔大厅（Grindles Hall），他花了两年时间才及格。牛津的主教
Grindles Hall and it takes him two years to pass. And the Bishop of Oxford is very dubious about ordaining him for the priesthood. He says this bloke is useless, he's not really committed, he obviously wants to be an actor, fine, and he gives in to a lot of pressure. So Harold becomes a curate at the Church of St Martin in the Fields in London. So their orchestra, the Academy of St. Martin in the Fields, has appeared with us at the Royal Albert Hall. So that's a lovely intersection point. And a church with a great commitment to the homeless, which in due course the Rector will demonstrate.
到了 1901 年，他基本上被赶到了一家与牛津有关的私立大厅——格林德尔大厅（Grindles Hall），他花了两年时间才及格。牛津的主教对按立他为神职人员感到非常犹豫。他说这个家伙毫无用处，根本不投入，他显然想当演员，好吧，最终他在巨大压力下妥协了。于是哈罗德成了伦敦圣马田教堂（St Martin-in-the-Fields）的助理牧师。所以他们的乐团——圣马丁乐团（Academy of St. Martin in the Fields）——曾和我们一起在皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅（Royal Albert Hall）演出过。所以这是一个很好的交汇点。而且这是一间对无家可归者有着高度承诺的教堂，主任牧师日后也将身体力行。
Exactly. And then in 1903 he gets a brilliant break in North Norfolk, Alan Partridge's territory. He is offered a job as the rector of Stiffke St John and Stiffke St Mary and Morstan. Now some listeners will say Stiffke is it not pronounced Stukey as you used to believe Tom. But you know what I did some digging into this. The only thing that's pronounced Stookey is the local cockles, which are called Stukie blues,
完全正确。然后在 1903 年，他在北诺福克（North Norfolk）迎来了职业生涯的重大突破，那可是阿兰·帕帕奇（Alan Partridge）的地盘。有人向他提供了一份工作，担任圣菲克圣约翰（Stiffke St John）、圣菲克圣玛丽（Stiffke St Mary）以及莫斯坦（Morstan）的主任牧师。现在，有些听众会说，Stiffke 不应该像你以前以为的那样发音为 Stukey 吗，汤姆？但你知道吗，我对此进行了一番深挖。唯一发音为 Stukey 的是当地的鸟尾蛤（cockles），被称为 Stukie blues，
but the people of the area call the place Stifke. So Stifke is this village with about 350 people. It's got a few shops, it's got a pub, but it's a very good job. The job is in the gift of this bloke who's called the Marquis Townsend, who has had a very scandalous private life. Now as the curate of St. Martin in the Fields, Davidson had officiated a controversial wedding to a beauty called Gladys and he'd had to persuade Townsend's family to accept the match. So Townsend owes him a favor and Townsend says look I'll give you the living at this place Stiffke and he's got a Georgian rectory, he's got acres of farmland,
但当地人把那个地方称为 Stifke。所以 Stifke 这个村子大约有 350 人。那里有几家商店，有一家酒吧，但这是一份相当不错的工作。这份工作的任命权掌握在一个名叫汤森侯爵（Marquis Townsend）的家伙手里，他有着非常声名狼藉的私生活。作为圣马丁教堂的助理牧师，戴维森曾为一场颇具争议的婚礼主持过仪式，新娘是一个名叫格拉迪斯（Gladys）的美女，他当时还不得不说服汤森的家族接受这门婚事。所以汤森欠他人情，汤森便说：“听着，我把这个叫 Stiffke 的地方的牧师职位交给你。”那里有一座乔治王时代的牧师住宅（rectory），拥有数英亩的农田，
and he has an annual income of 500 pounds a year. Now, if you go onto the website, the academic website Measuring Worth, which charts relative values over time, in relative income terms, that is an income of 400,000 pounds in today's money. You can buy on that, can't you? You would think you could get by on it,
并且每年有 500 英镑的收入。现在，如果你上学术网站 Measuring Worth（该网站记录了不同时期的相对价值），按相对收入计算，这相当于今天 40 万英镑的收入。靠这个你能过日子，不是吗？你本会以为靠它能过得去，
but not if you're a man like Harold Davidson. So now he can get married. He's been courting of course an actress, a blonde Irish actress called Molly Sorin and they get married and between 1907 and 1913 they have four children. Davidson is still very committed to his social work. He goes off to London a lot in the week. He works in these kind of East End settlement houses. And actually in the village, he is popular with the poorer residents. He's known as somebody who's very kind-hearted, who lends them money to help with their bills and their rent. And people nickname him Little Jimmy. Now, I don't
但如果你是哈罗德·戴维森这样的人，那就另当别论了。现在他可以结婚了。他当然一直在追求一个女演员，一个名叫莫莉·索林（Moly Sorin）的金发爱尔兰女演员，他们结婚了，在 1907 年到 1913 年间，他们有了四个孩子。戴维森仍然非常投入他的社会工作。他经常在工作日去伦敦。他在东区的这种社会福利馆工作。事实上在村里，他在穷人中很受欢迎。他被称为一个非常善良的人，借钱给他们支付账单和房租。人们给他起了个外号叫“小吉米”（Little Jimmy）。现在，我不知道
know why Jimmy, but they nicknamed him Little Jimmy. and they say he's a sort of friend of the poor man You know people like him for that. Yeah, and also he falls out with the local landowner doesn't he a Colonel groom? Yes, and Davidson has rebuked groom for keeping a mistress the irony, but maybe there's an element of kind of class Tension there. I think a political dimension. I think he's a do-gooder He's a social reform kind of person and some of the North Norfolk landowners don't really care for that. He also has these extracurricular interests so he's still spending a lot of time at the theatre and he will spend a lot of time backstage at West End theatres talking to people about the Bible. Even at this point
为什么叫吉米，但他们叫他“小吉米”。他们说他是穷人的朋友，你知道的，人们因此而喜欢他。是的，而且他还跟当地的地主闹翻了，不是吗？就是格鲁姆上校（Colonel Groom）？是的，戴维森曾斥责格鲁姆包养情妇，这真是莫大的讽刺，不过这其中可能也包含了一点阶级紧张的成分。我认为有政治层面。我认为他是一个乐善好施的人，是一个进行社会改良的人，而北诺福克的一些地主并不太喜欢这样。他还有这些课外兴趣，所以他仍然花大量时间在剧院里，并会花很多时候在西区剧院的后台跟人们谈论《圣经》。甚至到了这个时候，
people say it's interesting how the people he talks to, they all tend to be women of a certain age. You know, have you noticed this? Wearing skimpy costumes. Right, so by 1910 he's expanded his horizons to Paris and he goes to Paris every few weeks and he says I'm very happy to act as a chaperone for dancing girls who've been recruited by the Folly Bergère, these showgirls. And over time he starts to invite these girls back to the rectory in Norfolk. Sometimes he invites groups of them, up to 20 at a time. Now Molly doesn't like this and they start to argue very bitterly, but also the local gentry don't like it. They say, what, you
人们也说，有趣的是，他交谈的人往往都是一定年纪的女性。你知道吗，你注意到了吗？穿着暴露的服装。好吧，到了 1910 年，他把视野扩展到了巴黎，他每隔几周就会去一次巴黎，并表示他很乐意担任福来日歌剧院（Folies Bergère）招募的那些舞蹈演员、也就是这些歌舞女郎的伴护。随着时间的推移，他开始邀请这些女孩回到诺福克的主理牧师住宅。有时他会成群结队地邀请她们，一次多达 20 人。莫莉不喜欢这样，他们开始激烈争吵，而且当地的绅士阶层也不喜欢这样。他们说，什么，你知道的，我们不希望歌舞女郎出现在北诺福克。这到底是怎么回事？如果不是因为第一次世界大战，他可能早就被丑闻吞噬了。所以，就像阿斯奎斯（Asquith）因萨拉热窝的事件而在爱尔兰内战中解脱一样，哈罗德·戴维森也获救了。所以第一次世界大战也不完全是坏事？不，他志愿加入皇家海军担任神职人员，他的传记作家认为，这主要是因为牧师住宅里的关系不太好。莫莉对他对这些女孩的热情非常生气。所以首先，他登上了驻扎在设德兰群岛（Shetlands）的“直布罗陀号”HMS Gibraltar，他的传记作家找到了一份
know, we don't want showgirls in North Norfolk. What's all this? Now he might have been consumed by scandal earlier, were it not for the First World War. So just as Asquith was rescued from civil war in Ireland by the events in Sarajevo, so Harold Davidson is rescued. So the First World War not all bad? No, he volunteers to join the Royal Navies of Chaplin and this is probably his biographers think because basically relations in the rector are not good. Molly is very cross with him about his enthusiasm for these girls. So first of all he goes on to HMS Gibraltar which is stationed in the Shetlands and his biographers have found a
舰长的服役报告，舰长说他简直一无是处。敷衍了事地履行职责，与同舱伙伴关系不融洽，无视食堂的规章制度。但随后他被调到了东地中海的“福克斯号”HMS Fox，在这里，也许是一个不祥的征兆，警察突袭了开罗的一家妓院，却发现他在里面，他说：“哦，感谢上帝你们来了，我一直在寻找一个把性病传染给我手下的妓女。”因为事实是，随着故事的发展，这类解释成了故事的一个特色，它们不断涌现。正如你所说的那样，多米尼克，听众必须决定在接受这些解释的真实性与否时，是要保持仁慈还是不予理睬。
service report from the captain who says he was absolutely useless. Performs his duties in a perfunctory manner not on good terms with messmates, disregards mess rules and regulations. But then he's moved to HMS Fox in the eastern Mediterranean and here, perhaps an ominous sign, the police raid a brothel in Cairo and they find him in there and he says, oh thank God you've come, I've been searching for a prostitute who's been infecting my men with VD. Because the thing is that these kinds of explanations are a feature of the story as it develops and they keep cropping up and as you said Dominic, listeners have to decide whether they want to be charitable or not in accepting the truth or otherwise of these explanations.
我认为一个因为担心手下健康而去了妓院的神职人员，我认为这值得赞扬。你不这么觉得吗？我是这么觉得，但同时也有点像“我在开罗的妓院里”这种微妙的辩解。完全正确。他们在想什么呢？好吧，战争在 1919 年结束，他回到家里，迎来了晴天霹雳，事实上是一个非常悲伤的晴天霹雳。他的妻子莫莉怀孕六个月了，但在六个月前，
I think a clergyman who goes to a brothel because he's worried about the health of his men, I think that's commendable. Don't you? I do, but also there's a slight kind of me in a brothel in Cairo. Exactly. What were they thinking? Well the war ends in 1919, he returns home to a bombshell, actually a very sad bombshell. His wife Molly is six months pregnant but six months earlier
他在开罗，不在诺福克，所以当他们的女儿在 1919 年 6 月出生时，并不是他的孩子。乔纳森·塔基特认为，孩子的父亲是哈罗德·戴维森的老同学，这就太卑鄙了。这个女儿长得很像他，对吧，所以他某种程度上可以蒙混过关。是的，她确实长得很像他。这位老同学现在是加拿大军队的一名上校，曾在 1918 年下半年在莫莉家住过。无论如何，戴维森对此表现得相当大度。他说：“好吧，我会把这个女孩当成我自己的孩子。”我认为现在牧师住宅里的气氛非常紧张。因此，他在伦敦呆的时间越来越多，在这里我们也许应该谈谈他的日常作息。他会在每周一的第一时间离开家，在伦敦呆上一整周，而不是在诺福克，然后他要么在周六深夜非常非常晚的时候回家，要么越来越频繁地赶周日早上五点钟的火车，如果运气好的话，这能让他刚好赶上教堂。我催促着他，穿上法衣。没错，而且经常有关于他拼命从车站骑自行车、一路狂蹬、甚至骑车冲过教堂中殿来到圣坛前，然后下车开始做礼拜的故事。所以作为一个教区牧师，他实际上每周只在那里呆一天，有时甚至
he was in Cairo he was not in Norfolk so when their daughter is born in June 1919 she's not his. Jonathan Tucker thinks that the father was an old school friend of Harold Davidson that's low. The daughter looks like him doesn't she so he can kind of get away with it. Yes she does she looks just like him. This school friend is now a Colonel in the Canadian Army who had come to stay with Molly in the second half of 1918. Anyway Davidson, he's pretty good about it. He says, well I will accept the girl as my own. I think the atmosphere now is very tense in the rectory. So he's spending more and more time in London and here we should perhaps talk about his routine. He will leave home first thing every Monday morning and he will spend the whole
连这都勉强。他做的事就是像往常一样在剧院周围闲逛，他还是考芬园（Covent Garden）演员教堂（圣保罗教堂，St Paul's）的兼职牧师，但他真正全身心投入的是拯救伦敦女孩的使命。举个例子来说明这是如何运作的，他最喜欢的女孩可能是一个名叫罗斯·埃利斯（Rose Ellis）的女孩，这是一个无家可归的妓女，他于 1920 年在莱斯特广场（Leicester Square）遇到了她。
of the week in London, not in Norfolk, and then he will come home either very, very late on Saturday night or increasingly he gets the five o'clock in the morning train on Sunday and that if he's lucky will allow him to get to the church just in time. I'm rushing him, put his surplus on. Right, and often there are stories about him desperately peddling on his bike from the station and literally peddling up the aisle to the altar, getting off his bike and starting the service. So as a parish priest, he's actually only there one day a week and sometimes barely
他给了她租房间的现金。他每周都见她。有时他会把她带到诺福克的牧师住宅。他让她在花园里干活，并试图帮她安排演艺工作。但罗斯只是众多女孩中的一个，因为任何认为“哦，20世纪20年代的伦敦全都是老古董或者非常无聊”的人，都大错特错了。伦敦市中心以流莺和街头站街女而闻名。街上大概有 25,000 名妓女，
even that. What he's doing is he's hanging around the theatres as usual, he's also a part-time chaplain at the Actors' Church which is St Paul's in Covent Garden, but what he's really thrown himself into is his mission to rescue the girls of London. So to give you an example of how this works, probably his favorite of all the girls was a girl called Rose Ellis, who was a homeless prostitute whom he met in Leicester Square in 1920.
还有近卫军士兵，不是吗？没错，近卫军士兵。我需要一两先令。所以这些女孩中有很多是前佣人、农家女或女店员，她们在某些方面遇到了麻烦，来到伦敦试图重新开始，但并没有真正成功。所以戴维森有很多，我们可以这样说，供他挑选的“新兵”。正如他自己所说，他平均每年物色 150 到 200 个女孩。这是一句引语。“物色（Picked up）”是他的用词。同样，这也许是一个略显不够审慎的词汇的选择。正如罗纳德·布莱思所指出的那样，他最大的错误在于他并不加甄别。他认为，我引述一下，
And he gave her cash for a room. He met her every week. He sometimes would bring her up to Norfolk to the rectory. He would get her to work in the garden and he would try to fix her up with acting jobs. But Rose is just one of many girls because anybody who thinks oh London in the 1920s is all very starchy or very boring, you're wrong. Central London was notorious for working girls for street walkers. There were probably about 25,000 prostitutes on the
从 15 岁开始的每个年轻女孩都是需要被拯救的堕落女性。所以他会在剧院周围闲逛，他去皮卡迪利广场（Piccadilly Circus）或莱斯特广场，那是当年招揽妓女的地方，但他对茶室里的女服务员（也就是“尼皮斯（nippies）”，比如狮子茶坊连锁店等等）有着特殊的偏爱。正如罗纳德·布莱思所说，他是个易受……那种淀粉亚麻布在年轻乳房上爆裂时发出的妙不可言的和声、黑色长筒袜小腿、以及女仆裙边下方的饱满小腿吸引的傻瓜。他喜欢这一切。所以他走进茶室，她们走过来端茶，然后他就开始大谈《圣经》。是的，我不知道《圣经》占了多少比重，我的意思是，《圣经》在某个时候确实发挥了作用。他经常做的是说：“噢，亲爱的，我能给你买杯饮料吗？”你知道的，“你什么时候下班？”
streets. And for guardsmen as well weren't they?, exactly, guardsmen. I need a bob or two. So a lot of these girls are former servants or farm girls or shop girls who have got into trouble in some way and have come to London to try and start again, but it hasn't really worked out. So Davidson has a lot of, shall we say, recruits to choose from. And as he says himself, he picked up on average 150 to 200 girls every year. That is a quotation. Picked up is his term. Again, perhaps a slightly injudicious choice of words. His great error, as Ronald Blythe points out, is that he doesn't really discriminate. He sees, and I quote,
所有这类的话。这看起来相当无害。他会和她们聊很多关于舞台的事。“我在舞台上有很好的人脉。你会成为西区的一名出色的演员。”是的。诸如此类的话。他会倾听她们的烦恼，听她们的故事。
every young girl from 15 onwards as a fallen woman who needs to be saved. So he will hang around theatres, he goes to Piccadilly Circus or Leicester Square, the sort of the places where you pick up prostitutes in those days, but he has a particular ton dress for waitresses in tea shops, so nippies, so yeah, so like the lion's chain or whatever. So as Ronald Blythe puts it, he's a sucker for, the ineffable harmonies created by starched linen crackling over young breasts, black stocking calves, and chubby conference just below the hem
通常他会说：“我能为你找个地方住，一个更好的住处。我可以帮你安排更好的住所。我可以为你找一份女佣的工作，或者我可以让你和我的一些戏剧界朋友联系。”所以实际上，我的意思是，假以时日，当他……他陷入麻烦，人们试图弄清楚他在搞什么鬼时，一个不断出现、反复出现的词就是“纠缠（pestering）”，不是吗？
of the parlour maid's frock. He loves all this. So he's going into the tea rooms, they come up and serve tea, and then he starts talking about the Bible. Yes, I don't know how much the Bible, I mean, the Bible does play a part at some point. Quite often what he does is he will say, well, can I get you a drink, my dear? You know, when do you get off work?
我想有人说这就像留声机唱片里的某种重复。每当有证人描述他的接近方式时，他都是个纠缠不休的人。嗯，其中一些茶室实际上最终禁止他入内。他们觉得：又是他，真的在纠缠我们的女服务员。他就是不肯放过她们。但如果她们变得亲密，他会把她们带到 Stiffke 的牧师住宅去住，并做些零活。需要强调的是，我们谈论的不是 10 个女孩，也不是 20 个女孩，或者 30 个女孩。
All this kind of thing. It seems pretty innocuous. He'll talk to them a lot about the stage. I have great contacts on the stage. You would, you'd be a wonderful actress at the West end. Yeah. This kind of thing. He will listen to their woes, listen to their story.
我们谈论的是在 12 年的时间里，每年 200 个女孩。这是他自己的估计。所以我的意思是，成千上万。现在，所有这些都花了他很多钱……在 12 年的时间里。这是他自己的估计。所以我的意思是成千上万。现在所有这些都花了他很多钱。正如我们所听到的，他收入不错，但在这些女孩身上花的钱太多了，以至于收支不能相抵。大约在 1920 年，他遇到了一个名叫亚瑟·约翰·戈登（Arthur John Gordon）的男人。他说：“我是一个有钱的美国商人，我能帮你摆脱困境。”事实上，亚瑟·约翰·戈登是个彻头彻尾的骗子。他劝说戴维森把积蓄交给他，然后不断向他索要更多的钱。
Often he'll say, I can find you somewhere to stay a better place to stay. I can fix you up some better lodgings. I can find you a job as a domestic servant, or I can put you in touch with some of my theatrical friends. And so actually, I mean, in due course, when he, he gets into trouble and people are trying to work out what he'd been up to, the word that comes up again and again and again is pestering, isn't it?
这是一种典型的金字塔骗局。戴维森是个十足的蠢货，居然相信了他。五年后，他陷入了如此糟糕的境地，身无分文，连税单都付不起，面临着入狱的危险。他不得不向高利贷借钱，那年秋天他被宣布破产。但他仍然无法停止在伦敦花大量时间，把所有的钱都砸在女服务员身上。他现在去伦敦的部分原因也是为了寻找这个骗了他钱的家伙戈登，
And I think somebody says this is like a kind of a repetition in a gramophone record. Every time a witness describes his approach, he is a pesterer. Well some of these tea shops actually end up banning him. They're like, him again, really pestering our waitresses. He won't leave them alone. But he will bring them if they become close, he'll bring them to Stiffke to stay in the rectory and to do odd jobs. And just to stress, we're not talking about 10 girls or 20 girls or 30 girls.
所以这既是为了拯救女孩，也是为了拯救他个人的财务状况。确实如此。而且我想北诺福克对他的欢迎程度也日渐下降，因为他树敌众多，其中之一就是他的教堂司事（churchwarden），即菲利普·哈蒙德少校（Major Philip Hammond）。当然，他是个少校。所以哈蒙德少校，我查过他的资料，他在布尔战争（Boer War）中获得过勋章。他在西线战场赢得过军功十字勋章，当时他是坦克指挥官。所以他是个严肃认真的人。哈蒙德长期以来一直对牧师住宅里的所有这些女孩高度怀疑，他认为戴维森是个毫无用处的教区牧师，我想在很多方面他确实如此。
We're talking about 200 girls every year over a period of 12 years. That's by his own estimates. So I mean, thousands. Now all of this costs him a period of 12 years. That's by his own estimate. So I mean thousands. Now all of this costs him a lot of money. As we've heard he's making a good living but he's spending so much money on these girls that he can't make ends meet. And around 1920 he meets a man called Arthur John Gordon. He says I'm a rich American businessman and I can help you out. Actually Arthur John Gordon is a total con man. He persuades Davidson to give him his savings and then keeps asking him for more money.
是的，他从来不在，不是吗？是的，他从来不在。然后到了 1927 年，他们爆发了一场极其巨大、天崩地裂般的争吵，我必须说，我认为完全是戴维森的责任。哈蒙德的妻子丽塔（Rita）最近去世了，他决定清理莫斯坦教堂墓地里她坟墓周边的区域，莫斯坦是该教区的一部分，而戴维森对此反应激烈，大发雷霆。他给他写了一封信，说道：“莫斯坦教堂墓地是我的私人财产，未经我的许可，你无权以任何方式干涉它，就像
It's a classic pyramid scheme type thing. Davidson, a complete mug, believes him. Five years on, he's in such a mess, he has no money, he can't pay his tax bills and he's facing prison. He has to borrow money from money lenders and that autumn he is declared bankrupt. But he still can't stop himself from spending all this time in London and throwing all this money at waitresses. Also one of the reasons he's now going up to London is to try and find this guy, Gordon,
我无权来吞并你花园的一部分一样。”是的，这太疯狂了。这真的很欠考虑又很残忍。我认为那里面一定有积怨，因为你绝不会——如果你有一点点脑子，而且那家伙刚失去妻子——你绝不会，你知道的，你不会这么做。他似乎对上流社会的军人有一种特殊的厌恶。是的，我想是的。哈蒙德少校显然勃然大怒，并永远不会原谅他，决心伺机报复。
who's ripped him off. So it's about rescuing girls, but it's also about rescuing his own personal finances. It is indeed. And also I suppose North Norfolk is becoming an increasingly unwelcoming place for him because he has made an enemy of one of his church wardens, who is Major Philip Hammond. Of course, he's a major. So Major Hammond, I looked him up, he was decorated in the Boer War. He won a military cross on the Western Front where he was a tank commander. So he is a serious person. Hammond has long been very suspicious of all these girls at the rectory and he thinks Davidson is a useless parish priest, which I suppose in many ways he is.
三年后，即 1930 年 11 月，戴维森犯了一个可怕的错误。他在伦敦陪伴那些女士，结果没能及时赶回 Stiffke 参加村里战争纪念碑的停战日纪念仪式。我的意思是，当你想到这距离战争结束只有——你知道的，什么，12 年——时，这是一个多么疯狂的错误。我的意思是，这非常糟糕，观感实在太差了。哈蒙德少校简直气炸了。请记住，他是在第一次世界大战中获得勋章的军人。
Yeah, he's never there, is he? Yeah, he's never there. And then in 1927 they have an absolutely astronomical massive falling out, in which I have to say I think Davidson is completely to blame. Hammond's wife Rita has recently died and he decides to tidy up the area around her grave in the churchyard in Morstan which is part of the kind of the parish and Davidson goes absolutely ballistic and he sends him a letter and he says Morstan churchyard is my private property you have no right to interfere in it in any way without my permission, any more
而且还是教堂司事。是的，他说：“我要搞垮这家伙。”他向诺威奇主教（Bishop of Norwich）正式投诉了戴维森与女性的不当行为。很高兴诺威奇主教再次回归节目。是的。这位主教，我认为比他的前任要好。好吧，我们拭目以待。诺威奇主教说：“我不知道自己是不是真想卷入这事，”但他有一个名叫亨利·达什伍德（Henry Dashwood）的法律顾问，显然认为他们应该介入。亨利·达什伍德说：“我们真正应该做的是在公开法庭上把这事彻底抖落出来。有一种叫教堂宗教法庭（church consistory court）的东西，我们可以起诉主任牧师有不道德行为。如果他有罪，他可以被停职或被剥夺神职。他可以被赶出去，但我们需要证据。”
than I have the right to come and annex a part of your garden. Yeah, that's mad. That's really unthinking and cruel. I think there must have been bad blood there because you wouldn't go, surely if you had any brains at all and the blokes just lost his wife, you wouldn't, you know, you wouldn't do this. He seems to have a particular dislike for upper class military men. Yes, I think so. Major Hammond obviously is furious and never forgives him and is determined
于是达什伍德雇了一个私家侦探，侦探追踪到了这个名叫罗斯·埃利斯的女孩，她曾是戴维森的最爱。他给这个女孩灌波特酒和柠檬汁，一大桶一大桶的波特酒和柠檬汁。她喝得酩酊大醉，然后把整个故事全盘托出。他借钱给她，带她出去，做这做那。但并没有什么太坏的事情爆出来，不是吗？不，就是这样。所以有一个事件我们会在下半场再谈。
to get his own back. Then three years later, November 1930, Davidson makes a terrible mistake. He's in London with the ladies and he fails to make it back to Stiffke in time for the Armistice Day ceremony at the Village War Memorial. I mean, when you think this is within, you know, what, 12 years at the end of the war, this is a mad mistake to have made. I mean, it's a very bad, it's a really bad look. Major Hammond is absolutely outraged. Remember, decorated in the First World War.
跟屁股有关的。是的。他游说我割开他屁股上的一个疖子。好吧，仅此而已。除此之外就没什么了。与此同时，戴维森本人也风闻了这一切正在发生。他在向主教抗议自己的清白。他在 1931 年 12 月给主教写了一封气势磅礴的信，
And a church warden Yeah, he says I will bring this guy down and he makes a formal complaint to the Bishop of Norwich about Davidson's behavior with women And it's great to have the Bishop of Norwich back on the show. Yeah. Yes So the bishop but a better man, I think that his predecessor Well, we'll see the Bishop of Norwich says I don't know whether I really want to get involved in this, but he has a legal counsel called Henry Dashwood, who clearly thinks they should get involved. And Henry Dashwood says, what we ought to do really is to have this out in open court. There's a thing called a church consistory court and we can prosecute the rector for immoral acts. And if he's guilty, he can be suspended or he can be defrocked. He can be kicked out, but we need evidence.
汤姆，你想读一下这封信吗？多年来，我一直被称为“妓女的神父”。对我来说，这是基督真正的信徒所能拥有的最骄傲的称号。我笃信不疑，如果他在现今的伦敦重生，人们会发现他不断地在皮卡迪利大街漫步。所以任何想遇见基督的人，都去皮卡迪利大街吧。完全正确。是的，他说基督遭受了所有这些诽谤，但他照顾了那个行淫时被拿的妇人。他和抹大拉（Magdala）那个声名狼藉的妓女是好朋友。
So Dashwood hires a private detective and she tracks down this girl, Rose Ellis, who was Davidson's favorite. He pours port and lemon into this girl, vast buckets of port and lemon. She gets absolutely wasted and she tells all the whole story. He lends her money, he takes her out, he does this, that and the other. But nothing too bad comes out of it, does it? No, this is the thing. So there's one incident which will come back to the second half.
令人难以置信的是这位主教。我不知道他是否完全被说服了，但他似乎挺高兴的。但你知道吗？我的意思是，戴维森并没有错。我的意思是，耶稣在福音书中确实因与妓女厮混而受到批评。他确实如此。也许所有的神父和大主教都应该这么做。我只想说，这是一个始终存在的选项。
Buttock related. Yes. He persuaded me to lance a boil on his bottom. Right, but that's it. There's nothing beyond that. Meanwhile, Davidson himself has got wind of all this going on. He's protesting his innocence to the bishop. He writes him a tremendous letter, December 1931.
好吧，这绝对是戴维森选择的选项。他拥抱了它，我想这样说很公平。无论如何，难以置信的是，主教似乎经受住了诱惑，想把整件事大事化小。但接着在 1932 年 2 月 7 日，一个改变了整个案件全貌的重磅炸弹袭来。主教收到了一封来自一个名叫芭芭拉·哈里斯（Barbara Harris）的 17 岁女孩的信。她说：“我认识戴维森两年了，”引述如下，“我知道很多对你不利、可能会有帮助的事情。他有
Tom, would you like to read the letter? For years I have been known as the prostitute's Padre. To me the proudest title that a true priest of Christ can hold. I believe with all my soul that if he were born again in London in the present day, he would be found constantly walking in Piccadilly. So anyone who wants to meet Christ, head to Piccadilly. Exactly. Yes, he says Christ suffered all this slander, but he looked after the woman taken in adultery. He was great friends with the notorious harlot of Magdala.
很多女孩公寓的钥匙和前门钥匙。”让我们休息一下，等我们回来时，我们将了解巴布斯·哈里斯（Babs Harris）要揭露的全部细节。哈喽，欢迎回到《历史的 rest》。今天是 1932 年 3 月 29 日，我们位于威斯敏斯特的教会大厦（Church House），宗教法庭即将在那里听取对 Stiffke 主任牧师哈罗德·戴维森（Harold Davidson）审判的开案陈词，多米尼克。他被指控与行为不端的女性交往，并为了不道德的目的搭讪、骚扰和纠缠年轻女性。对哈罗德·戴维森来说，伟大的英国公众对
And the unbelievable thing is the bishop. I don't know if he's totally convinced, but he seems pretty happy. But you know what? I mean, Davidson isn't wrong. I mean, Jesus in the gospels does get criticized for hanging out with prostitutes. He does. Maybe all priests and prelates should do that. All I'm saying is it is an option that's always there.
那些到处与行为不端的女性鬼混的牧师毫无兴趣，这算不算他的幸运？毫无兴趣。还是说他们有兴趣？嗯，我想如果你身处 20 世纪 30 年代，如果你生活在 20 世纪 30 年代，听说一个牧师被指控纠缠女性，那简直就是梦想成真。你绝对会关注的。你绝对会关注的。完全正确。正如罗纳德·布莱思所说，当案件开庭时，Stiffke 变得和巴比伦一样声名狼藉，其名声甚至不亚于阿尔·卡彭（Al Capone）。关键是，这对报纸来说更棒了。他们
Well, it's an option that Davidson has undoubtedly taken. He's embraced it, I think it would be fair to say. Anyway, the bishop unbelievably seems tempted to let the whole thing drop. But then on the 7th of February, 1932, a bombshell that changes the whole complexion of the case. The bishop gets a letter from a 17-year-old girl called Barbara Harris. She says, I have known Davidson for two years, quote, I know lots of things against him that might help you. He has the keys of
不必去北诺福克，因为英国圣公会太抠门了，不愿意花钱把证人带到诺福克，所以他们说“为了省钱，我们在伦敦审理吧”，但当然这给记者们送上了一份大礼。所以这场审判在 3 月底开庭，控方由刑事辩护界的大腕之一罗兰·奥利弗爵士（Sir Roland Oliver Casey）领衔，他的头号证人就是这个名叫巴布斯·芭芭拉·哈里斯（Babs Barbara Harris）的女人。她现在 17 岁。她说：“我在 1930 年 9 月在大理石拱门（Marble Arch）遇到了戴维森。当时她正是罗纳德·布莱思所说的那个‘经验极其丰富的十六岁半’。她说，戴维森假装把她误认为是一位著名的女演员，并说服她和他一起喝茶。”
a lot of girls flats and front doors. Let's take a break and when we come back, we will find out the full detail of what Babs Harris has to reveal. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History. The date is the 29th of March 1932 and we are in Church House in Westminster where a consistory court is about to hear the opening statements in the trial of the rector of Stiffke, Harold Davidson and Dominic. He stands accused of associating with women of loose character and also of accosting, molesting and impotuning young females for immoral purposes. And it's lucky for Harold Davidson, isn't it, that the great British public take no
有很多年轻女孩的公寓和前门。我们先休息一下，回来后将为您揭晓芭比·哈里斯要透露的全部细节。您好，欢迎回到《历史的剩余部分》。今天是1932年3月29日，我们在威斯敏斯特的教堂大厦，一个宗教法庭即将在那里听取对斯蒂夫克牧师哈罗德·戴维森审判的开场陈述，多米尼克。他被指控与品行不端的女性交往，并被指控为了不道德的目的搭讪、骚扰和纠缠年轻女性。这对哈罗德·戴维森来说很幸运，不是吗，伟大的英国公众根本不
interest in the thought of vickers who go around consulting with women of loose character. No interest at all. Or do they? Well, I think if you're in the 1930s, if you live in the 1930s and you hear of a vicar who's been accused of impotuning, that is a dream. You're all over it. You're all over it. Exactly. As Ronald Blythe says, by the time the case opened, Stiffke was as notorious as Babylon and it's incumbent to celebrate it as Al Capone. And the thing is, it's even better for the newspapers. They
对那些四处与品行不端的女性密谋的牧师感兴趣。一点兴趣也没有。真的是这样吗？嗯，我想如果你在20世纪30年代，如果你生活在20世纪30年代，你听到一个牧师被指控纠缠女性，那简直是个梦幻般的八卦。你们绝对会趋之若鹜。绝对会。没错。正如罗纳德·布莱思所说，当案件开庭时，斯蒂夫克就像巴比伦一样声名狼藉，它甚至值得像阿尔·卡蓬那样被大肆庆祝。关键是，这对报纸来说更棒了，他们
don't have to go to North Norfolk because the Church of England is so cheap that they can't they don't want to have to pay to take witnesses to Norfolk so they say well we'll do it in London to save money but of course that's a gift to the reporters. So this trial opens at the end of March the prosecution is led by one of the stars of the criminal bar Sir Roland Oliver Casey and his star witness is this woman Babs Barbara Harris. She's now 17. And she says, I met Davidson in Marble Arch in September 1930. At that point she was what Ronald Blythe calls a highly experienced 16 and a half. Davidson, she says, pretended to mistake her for a well-known actress and persuaded her to have tea with him.
甚至不用去北诺福克，因为英国圣公会太吝啬了，他们不想出钱带证人去诺福克，所以他们说，为了省钱，我们把审判放在伦敦举行，但这当然成了记者们的福音。于是这场审判在三月底开庭，控方由刑事辩护界的明星之一罗兰·奥利弗·凯西爵士领导，他的明星证人就是这个叫芭比·芭芭拉·哈里斯的女人。她现在17岁。她说，她于1930年9月在大理石拱门遇到了戴维森。当时她被罗纳德·布莱思称为一个“经验极为丰富”的16岁半女孩。她说，戴维森假装把她认成了一位知名女演员，并说服她和他一起喝茶。
And this is a favourite kind of tactic of his. It is. Later on, he visited her lodgings. He got her address and he visited her lodgings telling her landlady that he was her uncle. She was at that point living with an Indian policeman. But when Davison turned up at two o'clock in the morning, they didn't mind at all. He made a point of saying to them, oh, it's fine, you're in bed, you know, you're not married, whatever. But actually,
这也是他最喜欢的策略之一。确实是的。后来，他去拜访了她的住处。他弄到了她的地址，拜访了她的住处，并告诉她的房东太太他是她的叔叔。当时她和一个印度警察住在一起。但当戴维森在凌晨两点出现时，他们一点也不介意。他特意对他们说，哦，没关系，你们在床上嘛，你知道的，又没结婚，诸如此类的话。但实际上，
God does not mind sins of the body. He only minds sins of the soul. And Dominic, this is a reflection that is inspired by tales that the Indian policeman has been telling about temple girls back in India. And I kind of thought when I was, I reread the chapter, we are only three and a half decades before the summer of love in the 1960s. And there's a sense in which poor old Harold Davidson is a man out of time, because that mixing of interest in Eastern religion,
上帝并不介意肉体的罪。他只介意灵魂的罪。多米尼克，这是一个由印度警察以前在印度讲过的关于庙妓的故事所引发的感慨。当我重新阅读这一章时，我突然想到，我们距离20世纪60年代的爱之夏只有短短三十五年。某种意义上说，可怜的老哈罗德·戴维森是一个生不逢时的人，因为那种对东方宗教、
ecumenicism and sexual liberation, I mean, he'd have been much happier in the 60s than in the 30s. Yeah, yeah, absolutely right. Do you know what though, I have a theory and I've always had this theory that the 1930s are actually a little bit of a dry run for the 1960s. There's more similarities between those two decades than people think. The rector born in the wrong decade. Exactly. So he starts to stay overnight at Babs's lodgings, especially when the policeman
普世主义和性解放的兴趣融合，我的意思是，他在60年代会比在30年代过得快乐得多。对，对，完全正确。不过你知道吗，我有一个理论，而且我一直有这个理论，那就是20世纪30年代其实是60年代的一次小规模预演。这两个十年之间的相似之处比人们想象的要多。这位牧师生错了年代。一点没错。于是他开始在巴巴的住处过夜，特别是当那个警察
goes home to India. Barbara Harris says, at first he kept to the chair, but after the first few nights he did not. She claimed that he made advances to her, but she wasn't interested, so, and I quote, he relieved himself. He got her to come and stay at Stiffke Rectory. She said actually this element of it has been slightly glamourised, it's not as exciting as you might think. When I arrived at the rector, he asked me to work as a kitchen
回印度的时候。芭芭拉·哈里斯说，起初他一直待在椅子上，但过了头几个晚上之后就不这样了。她声称他向她求欢，但她不感兴趣，所以，我引用一下，“他自己解决了。”他让她来斯蒂夫克牧师住宅住。她说其实这部分被稍微美化了，并没有你想的那么刺激。当我到达牧师住宅时，他让我做厨房
maid and for no money. Yeah, I told him to sleep in the chair. Anyway, she's a tremendous character. So when the defence lawyer questions her, it gets better and better. It turns out, as Ronald Blythe puts it, her real name was Gwendolyn. She'd made love with many men, including some Indians. She had left school at 14 and from then on she'd helped herself. When she'd not got a job, she stayed in bed until 11 or more in the morning. She liked all the men she'd known. She was always happy.
女佣，而且不给工钱。是的，我叫他睡在椅子上。总之，她是一个了不起的人物。所以当辩护律师盘问她时，情况变得越来越好。正如罗纳德·布莱思所说，事实证明她的真名叫格温多琳。她和许多男人发生过性关系，其中包括一些印度人。她14岁就辍学了，从那时起她就靠自己丰衣足食。如果没有工作，她就会睡到上午11点甚至更晚。她喜欢她认识的所有男人。她总是很高兴。
She liked reading. No, she hadn't had VD, but one she thought she had. Silly me, she implied cheerfully. And actually Blythe's discussion of the trial is very, very funny. And what he captures is just what a mad comedy it is. And actually, Davidson himself, who of course had acted in Farces and Lights Entertainment, is determined to behave as though he's on the stage. So he's chuckling and winking and making ridiculous asides and all of this stuff. And of course, all of this is brilliant for the newspapers. As to quote Blythe again, it gives them a combination of prelates, waitresses,
她喜欢读书。不，她没有得过性病，但她曾经以为自己得过。“我真傻，”她开朗地暗示道。实际上，布莱思对这场审审判的讨论非常非常有趣。他所捕捉到的正是这是一部多么疯狂的喜剧。事实上，戴维森本人曾演过滑稽剧和轻娱乐节目，他决心表现得好像自己还在舞台上一样。所以他咯咯笑着、眨着眼，还说些荒谬的题外话等等。当然，所有这一切对报纸来说都是绝佳的素材。正如再次引用布莱思的话，这为他们提供了一种结合体，包括高级神职人员、女服务员、
strongmen, hunting church wardens, amorous Indian youths, publicans, landlady, dentists, titled female do-gooders, the fully-beige, bathing suits, photographs, train journeys, and every possible variation on the popular prurient theme of virtue exposed. I mean, there's a sense, isn't there, in which this is the archetype for every kind of tabloid scandal that will follow. All the ingredients are there. This is the ultimate. It can never really be exceeded. And in a sense, journalists right the way up into the 1990s are simply trying to reheat
大力士、喜欢打猎的教堂司事、多情的印度青年、酒店老板、房东太太、牙医、有名望的女慈善家、全套米色衣服、泳衣、照片、火车旅行，以及对美德暴露这一流行窥阴癖主题的各种可能变体。我的意思是，从某种意义上说，这不正是随后所有小报丑闻的原型吗？所有的元素都在这里。这是终极版本。它永远不可能真正被超越。从某种意义上说，一直到20世纪90年代的记者们都只是在试图重新加热
this. Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. Now the funny thing is it goes on so long that Davidson runs out of money. He can't pay his defense team and unbelievably the prosecution actually give him money so that the trial can continue. Now his defense team, their argument is this is completely unfair and everyone has the wrong idea that he's not morally corrupt. He's just well-meaning and a little bit naive, and his defence lawyer says, you know, there's a lot of talk about
这个冷饭。是的，我认为完全正确。有趣的是，这件事持续了这么久，以至于戴维森把钱花光了。他支付不起辩护团队的费用，难以置信的是，控方竟然给他钱，好让审判能够继续下去。现在他的辩护团队，他们的论点是这完全不公平，所有人都对他的道德败坏有错误的看法。他只是好心却有点天真，他的辩护律师说，你知道的，有很多关于
him kissing women, but he kisses everybody, not in a sexual or sensual way, it's the usual gesture for him when leaving someone he likes or if they've done something for him. Now you might say, well come on, I don't believe this, but I actually think this could well be true. In all the parade of witnesses, the only one who accuses him of indecency is Barbara Harris. And she's kind of the most meretricious of the witnesses, would you say? So Jonathan Tucker thinks that she was coached by the rector's enemies. He points out the guy who's presiding over the trial is a great friend of the Bishop of Norwich. So the whole thing is slightly rigged. And that letter
他亲吻女性的议论，但他亲吻所有人，这不是出于性或感官的方式，这是他在离开喜欢的人或别人为他做过事时的常规手势。现在你可能会说，得了吧，我才不信呢，但我其实觉得这很可能是真的。在所有的证人中，唯一指控他不道德的人是芭芭拉·哈里斯。你会说，她可以说是其中最虚伪的证人吗？所以乔纳森·塔克认为她受到了牧师敌人们的指使。他指出，主持审判的那个人是诺威奇主教的挚友。所以整件事稍微被操纵了。还有那封
that blew the whole thing open, I think it's generally agreed now that she didn't write it, that it was a fake, that it was probably written by somebody else, one of his enemies, with her connivance possibly. And just to add, I mean, you say how the tone is comic. I mean, it is, and that's why it's such a kind of richly and fondly remembered story in so many ways. But it is Barbara Harris, or people who are manipulating her, who does introduce a slight darker element to the story. So she says that he gave her a black eye at one point, and that he recommended that she go and work in a brothel. That sounds very out of character. But again, we're kind of left with, you know, do you believe the worst of him or do you think he's very hard treated?
把事情彻底捅破的信，现在普遍认为不是她写的，而是一封伪造的信，很可能是由其他人、他的某个敌人写的，可能还得到了她的默许。顺便补充一下，我的意思是，你说了基调是如何具有喜剧色彩的。我的意思是，确实如此，这也是为什么这个故事在很多方面都是一个如此丰富且充满温情被铭记的故事。但正是芭芭拉·哈里斯，或者操纵她的人，为这个故事引入了一点更黑暗的元素。所以她说他曾打过她黑眼圈，并且建议她去妓院工作。这听起来非常不符合他的性格。但话又说回来，我们有点不知所措，你知道的，你是相信他最坏的一面，还是觉得他受到了严厉的对待？
I mean, it's very, you know, you've got to essentially decide what you think, I guess. Well on her, I think it is very clear that she is making stuff up and she freely admits, by the way, that she will say anything for money and's she keeps changing her story and making a great joke of It's and everybody laughs But there's no doubt I think that she was you know I I would not be surprised at all if she'd taken money from Davidson's enemies and she's just Randomly saying whatever comes into her head because every other witness and we're talking about landlady's waitresses shop girls,
我的意思是，这非常，你知道的，你基本上得决定你怎么想，我猜。至于她，我认为很清楚她在胡编乱造，顺便她也直言不讳地承认，为了钱她什么话都说得出口，而且她不断改变说法，还把这当成一个大笑话，大家都笑了。但毫无疑问，我认为她——你知道，如果她拿了戴维森敌人的钱，我一点也不觉得奇怪，她只是随机地说任何脑子里蹦出来的话，因为其他所有的证人和我们谈论的是房东太太、女服务员、店员工，
show girls, none of them say that he tried to sleep with them. They basically say he's a pest, he can be a bore, possibly he's a little bit too familiar, you know, kind of kissing them goodbye and all of that kind of thing and stroking them and stuff. But that's it. And although it's true, you might say he's a little bit of a weirdo. I mean, are not a lot of vikas slightly unusual? But also, I mean, we talked about how he loves a farce, how these were the kind of plays that he acted in as a young man. And bedroom farces in particular invariably involve and bedroom fasts in particular invariably involve vickers being discovered in cupboards with French maids, and there's a completely innocent explanation.
歌舞女郎，没有一个人说他试图跟他们上床。他们基本上说他是个讨厌鬼，可能会让人厌烦，可能有点过于轻浮，你知道的，比如告别时亲吻他们以及所有这类事情，还有抚摸他们等等。但也就这样了。尽管确实如此，你可能会说他有点怪。我的意思是，难道很多牧师不都有点不寻常吗？但同时，我的意思是，我们讨论了他如何热爱滑稽剧，这些是他年轻时演出的那种戏剧。尤其是卧室滑稽剧，总是涉及——尤其是卧室滑稽剧总是涉及牧师被发现在壁橱里和法国女佣在一起，而这有一个完全无辜的解释。
And there are two such incidents that are revealed in this trial, aren't there? They're both related to buttocks, actually. So the first one is this business about whether this girl, Rose Ellis, lanced a boil on his buttock. He's asked this and he says to the court, well, I don't know what the word means. I don't know what a buttock is. And then he says, and I quote, "'It is a phrase I've honestly never heard.
这次审判中披露了这样两起事件，不是吗？实际上都和屁股有关。所以第一件事是关于这个女孩罗丝·埃利斯是否切开了他屁股上的疖子的事。当被问及此事时，他对法庭说，嗯，我不知道这个词是什么意思。我不知道什么是屁股。然后他说，我引用一下，“这是一个我老实说从未听说过的词组。
So far as I remember, it is a little below the waist.'" And everybody just burst out laughing at this and says, come on, this is ridiculous. I obviously, I think he's doing it to get, he's actually genuinely doing it to get, he's actually genuinely doing it to get a laugh. I mean, obviously he knows what a buttock is, but this is his sort of the old farceur's instincts. Yeah. And not sensible timing. Not sensible timing. Now, the second buttock incident is perhaps more damning. This guy Sir Roland Oliver produces
就我所记得的，它在腰部以下一点点。”大家听了这话都哄堂大笑，说，得了吧，这太荒谬了。很明显，我认为他这么做是为了，他实际上真的是为了——他实际上真的是为了博得笑声。我的意思是，他显然知道屁股是什么，但这可以说是他那种老滑稽演员的本能。是的。而且时机不对。时机不对。现在，第二个关于屁股的事件可能更具定罪力度。这位叫罗兰·奥利弗爵士的人出示了一张
a photograph of Davidson in his clerical garb and tweed, isn't it? He's got tweed in a clerical collar, looking very serious. And he's sort of semi embracing a 15 year old girl called Estelle Douglas. We only see her from behind, but she is completely naked. So basically her buttocks are facing you. Now, Davidson says this was a massive setup. I've been tricked. He says I was asked to do a publicity photo to help her get work as an actress. I was wrapping her up in a shawl and I was led to believe that she, I couldn't see what was on the other side of
戴维森穿着牧师袍和花呢呢绒服的照片，对吧？他穿着花呢夹克和牧师领，看起来非常严肃。他半拥抱着一个15岁的女孩，名叫埃斯特尔·道格拉斯。我们只能看到她的背影，但她完全赤裸。基本上她的屁股正对着你。现在，戴维森说这是一个巨大的局。我被算计了。他说有人让我拍一张宣传照来帮她获得做演员的工作。我正在用一条披肩把他裹起来，而我被告知她——我看不见披肩的另一面是什么，并且我被告知她穿着泳衣，她并不是赤身裸体。现在我认为这是真的。我认为这张照片是由那个给罗丝·埃利斯灌了波特酒和柠檬汁的同一个私家侦探策划的，戴维森确实是被冤枉了。然而，这是一张荒谬的照片。它在互联网上。你可以在维基百科的词条上看到它，因为他看起来太严肃了，不是吗？这确实很有定罪力。法庭对这张照片一点也不买账。我的意思是，有些人甚至认为这张照片被动过手脚。不管怎样，这张照片对他很不利。法庭在6月初休庭。到这个时候，每当他去斯蒂夫克做礼拜时，都有成群的人在那里，你知道的，都是些看热闹的和游客。但他去得太不规律了，以至于教区开始派替代人选。6月12日发生了一件精彩的事件，他迟到了，礼拜已经开始了，
the shawl and I was led to believe that she had a bathing suit on and that she wasn't naked. Now I think this is true. I think the photograph was set up by the same private detective who had got Rose Ellis drunk on port and lemon and that Davidson genuinely was hard done by. However, it's a ludicrous photo. It's on the internet. You can see it on the Wikipedia entry because he looks so solemn, doesn't he? It is quite damning. The court is not impressed with this photo at all. I mean, some people actually think the photo was interfered with. Anyway, the photo is bad for him. The court adjourns in early June. By now, whenever he goes to Stiffke for services, there are tons of people there, you know, sort of
而他们派了一个替代者，名叫理查德·凯特尔牧师，他以前曾是英格兰橄榄球队长。戴维森冲进教堂，当着所有教区居民的面跟这个人争夺圣经。我的意思是，这太像吉夫斯和伍斯特的故事了。是的，确实是吉夫斯和伍斯特。凯特尔退让了，他对会众说：“我现在要离开了，因为很明显，除了武力之外，没有什么
goppers and tourists. But he turns up so irregularly, that the diocese has started sending replacements. There's a brilliant incident on the 12th of June, when he arrives late, the service has already started. and they've sent a substitute who's called the Reverend Richard Cattle who had previously been the England rugby captain. And Davidson rushes into the church and wrestles with this guy for the Bible in front of all the parishioners. I mean, it's so Jeeves and Worcester. Yeah, it is Jeeves and Worcester. Cattle gives way and he says to the congregation, I'm leaving now because it is clear that nothing
能阻止戴维森先生参与其中。”想必体型差异非常巨大。对，你大概会这么想，因为他是小吉米，还记得吗？那个划船的是个橄榄球运动员，肯定体型庞大。总之，在7月8日，法庭宣判了裁决。戴维森在五项不道德罪名上被判有罪，但疯狂的是，主教花了一个月的时间才宣布判决。与此同时，戴维森决定他需要筹集资金来支付他的诉讼费。
short of force will prevent Mr Davidson from taking part. Presumably there's a massive size disproportion. Yeah, you'd think so because he's little Jimmy, remember? And the boat is a rugby player, must be huge. Anyway, on the 8th of July, the court hands down its verdict. Davidson is guilty on five counts of immorality, but crazily, the bishop takes a month to announce the sentence. And in the meantime, Davidson decides he needs to raise money to pay his legal bills.
所以首先，他在温布尔登的公主电影院表演了一场杂耍，他演了两三天左右。然后他想，嗯，这还不够。我需要去更大的舞台，真正的黄金档，那就是黑潭。正如你所说，当时这里不仅是英国，也是欧洲最受欢迎的海滨度假胜地。现在想来真是令人惊叹。
And so first of all, he does a variety act at the Princess Cinema in Wimbledon, and he does this for a couple of days or whatever. And then he thinks, well, that wasn't enough. I need to go for the really big stage, the proper big time, and that is Blackpool. Which as you said, is the most popular seaside resort, not just in Britain, but in Europe at the time. It seems amazing to think now.
我一直觉得很有趣的是，去那里好几次的人之一是西格蒙德·弗洛伊德。弗洛伊德非常喜爱黑潭，以至于他在关于梦的解析一书中收录了在那里涉水的回忆。很明显，弗洛伊德关于你拥有自我，然后你拥有本我——那种你未曾承认的欲望和渴望的冲动的观点——肯定构成了人们试图理解这个故事的背景的一部分。现在人们意识到，也许，你知道的，一个牧师可以四处奔走试图拯救妓女，并且在意识层面上认为自己在做上帝的工作，但潜意识总是存在的。
And I always thought it's intriguing that one of the people who goes there several times is Sigmund Freud. And Freud adored Blackpool so much that memories of paddling in the waters there were included in his book on the interpretation of dreams. And clearly that Freudian idea that you have the ego and then you have the id, the kind of the unacknowledged promptings of your desires and yearnings, I mean, must be part of the context in which people are trying to make sense of this story. That there is an awareness now that maybe, you know, a vicar can go around trying to rescue prostitutes and may on his conscious level think that he's doing God's work, but the subconscious is always there.
我认为黑潭真的是他最终试图赚钱的绝佳地点。因为从某种意义上说，去黑潭的人都在寻找通过性和暴力来获得刺激，我认为在以前，人们不会承认这就是他们在做的事情。所以在黑潭，我的意思是，这是一个非常漂亮的度假胜地，在过去几十年里一直发展到20世纪30年代。正当戴维森去那里的时候，黑潭的杜莎夫人蜡像馆开放了一个新景点，其中包括从刚刚关闭的利物浦解剖学博物馆拿来的展品。那里的主题包括雌雄同体的生殖器官。有些展品涉及梅毒的
And I think Blackpool is the perfect place really for him to end up trying to make money. Because in a sense, people who go to Blackpool are looking to be titillated by sex and violence in a way that I think previously wouldn't have been acknowledged that this is what they were doing. So at Blackpool, I mean, it's incredibly handsome resort that's been developed over the previous few decades by the 1930s. As Davidson goes there, a new attraction has opened up at Madame Tussauds in Blackpool, which consists of exhibits taken from the Liverpool Museum of Anatomy, which has just shut. And topics there include the sexual parts of hermaphrodite. There are exhibits that deal with the effects
影响。其中一个展品展示了习惯性手淫者，并说明如果你手淫，你就会变得痴呆并陷入幼儿状态。然后那种你到那里去是为了享受一种优越感，去践踏那些通常可能比你更优秀的人的想法。所以有一个展品是一块价值一百几尼的地毯，它是一个杂耍艺人带到那里的，他说来冬花园在一块价值一百几尼的地毯上吐口水吧。所以有机会去看一个牧师、一个牛津大学毕业生、一个曾在一战中担任军官的人如何羞辱自己，我认为这就是吸引力的一部分，当然这也是为什么斯蒂夫克的牧师整个案件会成为如此
of syphilis. One exhibit displays the habitual masturbator and shows how if you masturbate you become idiotic and sink into second childhood. And then the idea that you go there in a sense to enjoy a sense of superiority, to trample down on those who might normally be your betters. So there's one display that is a hundred guinea carpet and it's been brought there by a showman and he says come to the winter gardens and spit on a hundred guinea carpet. So the chance to go and see a rector, an Oxford graduate, someone who has been an officer in the first world war to see him humiliate himself, I think that that is part of the appeal and of course that is part of why the whole case of the rector of Stiffke is such a the appeal and of course that is part of why the whole case
轰动全国的原因，也是我们今天坐在这里谈论它的原因。正是那种差距，不是吗，牧师的身份与他所陷入的羞辱之间的差距。哦，绝对是的。绝对是的。我的意思是，性是黑潭吸引力的很大一部分，顺便说一句。有所有这些来自比如大众观察组织在20世纪30年代进行的关于人们在小巷子里进行被称为膝盖颤抖的性行为的调查记录。牧师可没干那个。他实际做的是坐在一个木桶里，他说他是受到第欧根尼的启发。所以海滨大道上有个地方叫黄金英里，是一片景点区域。他坐在那个木桶里，旁边是猩猩女孩玛丽安娜和世界最胖的人迪克·哈罗，
of the rector of Stiffke is such a national sensation and why we're sitting here talking about it. It's that disjunction, isn't it, between the status of a rector and the humiliations that he's led into. Oh, definitely. Definitely. I mean, sex is a huge part of Blackpool's appeal, by the way. There are all these kind of accounts from like Mass Observation who did these surveys
他每天在这个木桶里坐上14个小时。那里有一个窗户，所以人们可以看到他在木桶里，还有一个烟囱，这样他就可以抽他的雪茄，成千上万的人来看他，但实际上，我不认为他赚了巨额的财富。而此时此刻，他正坐在木桶里，对吧？更精妙的改进还会在后面加上。完全正确。现在，他回到了斯蒂夫克。他与哈蒙德少校进行了一次最后的遭遇。他在8月到达准备讲道，却发现哈蒙德少校把他锁在教堂外面。于是他对坐在墓地里的上千人讲道。接着是一个离奇的场面，他又开始摔跤了——摔跤成了一个特色——他为了教堂的钥匙跟哈蒙德摔跤，而哈蒙德字面意义上把他踢下了
in the 1930s about people having knee tremblers as they were called and kind of back alleys and stuff. The rector's not doing that. What he's actually doing is sitting in a barrel and he's inspired, he says, by Diogenes. So on the seafront is a place called the Golden Mile, this stretch of kind of attractions. He sits in this barrel, he's next to Mariana the Gorilla Girl and Dick Harrow the world's fattest attractions. He sits in this barrel, he's next to Mariana the Gorilla Girl and Dick Harrow the world's fattest man and he sits in this barrel for 14 hours a day. There is a window so people can see him in the barrel and there is a chimney so that he can smoke his
台阶，戴维森抱怨了，结果哈蒙德因为踢人不得不支付了20先令的普通袭击罪罚款。好了，进入尾声。10月21日，他被传唤到诺维奇大教堂接受宣判。诺维奇大教堂接受宣判。又是诺维奇大教堂。是的。毫无疑问他迟到了。他连夜开车赶到那里。他给主教发了一封电报说，我是杰弗里，抱歉，我要迟到了。然后他到了。支持者们在他进去时为他欢呼。主教宣读，开始宣读判决。很显然他将被剥夺神职被踢出去。这非常
cigar and thousands of people come to see him but actually I don't think he makes an enormous amount of money. And at this point he is just sitting the barrel, isn't he? Further refinements will be added. Exactly. Now, he goes back to Stiffke. He has a final encounter with Major Hammond. He arrives to preach in August and he finds that Major Hammond has locked him out of the church. So he preaches to a thousand people sitting in the churchyard. Then there's a bizarre scene where he wrestles again, wrestling becoming a feature, he wrestles with Hammond for the keys of the church and Hammond literally kicks him down
像德雷福斯事件，德雷福斯被赶出法国军队那样。戴维森打断了他并发表了一场慷慨激昂的演讲。他说：“我是完全无辜的。我没有做过一件单薄的事，是在上帝的帮助下我不会再做一次的事。”而主教对他的申诉置若罔闻。“我们特此以全能的上帝、圣父、圣子、圣灵赋予我们的权威，罢免、解除并降职他。”那是一个绝佳的主教口音。谢谢。我想主教就是这么说话的。现在对其他人来说，这将是故事的结束，但对哈罗德·戴维森来说并非如此。他面临着巨额的律师费，因为既然他输了官司，他现在还得支付控方的诉讼费用。
the steps and Davidson complained and Hammond ended up having to pay a 20 shilling fine for assault, common assault for kicking him. Anyway, so to the end game. On the 21st of October he is summoned to Norwich Cathedral for sentencing. Norwich Cathedral for sentencing. Norwich Cathedral again. Yeah. Now inevitably he's late. He's driven through the night to get there. He sends the bishop a telegram to say, I'm Jeffery, sorry, I'm going to be late. Then he arrives. There are supporters there who cheer him when he goes in. The bishop reads out, starts reading the sentence. It's very clear that he's going to be defrocked to be kicked out. It's very
他怎么赚钱？显而易见的答案：回到木桶里去。所以在接下来的四个夏天里，他在黄金英里打工。现在木桶是他的招牌表演，但有一些有趣的变体。其中一个是他钻进一口装满冰块的开放式棺材里，他说我将躺在这口棺材里绝食，直到主教听到我的申诉。黑潭警方逮捕了他，说他企图自杀，这是个犯罪行为，但他实际上赢了这场官司，并获得了
like the Dreyfus case when Dreyfus is kind of kicked out of the French army. And Davidson interrupts him and gives a passionate speech. He says, I'm entirely innocent. There's not one single deed which I've done, which I wouldn't do again with the help of God. And the bishop deaf to his appeals. We hereby, by the authority committed to us by Almighty God, the Father, Son and Holy Ghost, remove, depose and degrade him. That's an excellent Episcopal accent. Thank you. That's how the bishop spoke, I think. Now for anybody else, that would be the end of the story, but not for Harold Davidson. He's facing massive legal bills because he has to pay the prosecution costs as well now that he's lost the case.
400英镑的赔偿金。这还真不赖。不过最受欢迎的是他的玻璃面烤箱。他会钻进这个玻璃面的烤箱里被烘烤，同时一个机械恶魔用烤肉叉戳他的屁股。又是屁股，那是什么主题？大约六年前在《星期日画报》上有一篇理查德·惠廷顿·埃根的精彩回忆录，他去过并描述了与牧师交谈的情景，他那动听的声音，融合了牛津口音和宗教语调的流畅声线。
How can he make money? The obvious answer, get back in the barrel. So for the next four summers, he works the golden mile. Now the barrel is his staple act, but there are interesting variations. So one of them is he gets into an open coffin filled with ice and he says I will lie in this coffin and starve myself until the bishop hears my appeal. The Blackpool police arrest him and they say he's trying to commit suicide and this is a crime but he actually wins the case and was awarded
而这个人，理查德·惠廷顿·埃根，一次又一次地去看他在玻璃棺材里的表演。他说，我们谈论了化石、埃德加·爱伦·坡的故事、开膛手杰克的谜团。然后可怜的理查德·惠廷顿·埃根不喜欢学校。牧师非常严厉地告诉他，这符合他曾作为皇家海军随军牧师的身份：永远坚守阵地，说真话，不畏惧任何人。所以这显然是牧师通过坐在充满冰块的棺材里或者被机械恶魔戳屁股来活出的道德教训。我的意思是，这还不是全部，对吧？
400 pounds in damages. That's not bad. The most popular thing though is his glass-fronted oven. He would get into this glass-fronted oven where he would be roasted while a mechanical devil poked him in the buttocks with a toasting fork. The buttocks again, what was that theme? There was a brilliant reminiscence of by a guy called Richard Whittington Egan in the Aldi about six years ago, who went and he describes talking to the rector, his beautiful voice, a mellifluous amalgam of the
所以他背负着可怕的债务。有一次警察甚至来到他的木桶旁因债务逮捕他。他说，我只需要走出去一秒钟。然后他在黑潭的海滨大道上狂奔，警察在后面紧追不舍。他进入他的公寓，把自己反锁在卧室里，打开窗户，顺着落水管爬下去，坐出租车逃跑了。他们最终追上了他，他被判入狱九天，其中大部分时间他不得不在监狱医务室度过，因为他在爬落水管时受了伤。
Oxford accent and ecclesiastical tone. And this guy, Richard Whittington Egan, went back again and again to see him in his glass coffin. He says, we talked to fossils, the stories of Edgar Allan Poe, the mystery of Jack the Ripper. And then poor Richard Whittington Egan doesn't like school. And the Rector tells him very sternly, befitting the Royal Naval Chaplain he had been, always stick to your guns, tell the truth and fear no man. So that is clearly the moral lesson that the Rector is living out by sitting in a coffin full of ice or having his buttocks jabbed by a mechanical demon. I mean, this is not all of it, right?
这只是他职业生涯此时那种巴洛克式疯狂的一种风味。还有羞辱。是的。他不得不做图书推销员。他在伦敦圣潘克拉斯车站短暂做过铁路搬运工。有一段时间他申请做黑潭足球俱乐部的经理。他有什么资格做那个吗？我想没有，因为我认为他没有什么体育背景。
So he's in terrible debt. And at one point the police actually arrive at his barrel to arrest him for debt. He says, I just need to step out for a second. And then he runs for it down the promenade and Blackpool with their officers in pursuit. He gets into his flat, he locks himself in the bedroom, he opens the window, he climbs down the drainpipe and escapes in a taxi. They catch up with him eventually and he's sent to prison for nine days, most of which he has to spend in the prison infirmary because he's been injured climbing down the drainpipe.
我的意思是，这会是一件有趣的事，对吧？无论如何，他没得到这份工作。很不幸，他依然没有戒掉对女孩的迷恋。所以在1936年末，我想是的，他因为再次在维多利亚车站纠缠两个16岁女孩而被罚款。他曾走到她们面前说，姑娘们，你们想不想成为西区演出中的女主角？看吧，现在他看起来又有点——有点可疑了。
And this is just a sort of flavor of the baroque madness of his career at this point. And the humiliation. Yeah. He has to work as a book salesman. He works briefly as a railway porter at St Pancras station in London. At one point he applies to be the manager of Blackpool football club. Did he have any qualifications to do that? I don't think so because I don't think he's got much of a sporting hinterland.
这有点可疑。是的。现在他的演艺生涯的问题在于，显然，你知道的，小报丑闻总是这样。人们的记性很短，他在黑潭正与一些相当性感的表演竞争。所以在20世纪30年代末，他的竞争对手包括来自俄罗斯的大胡子女士、狗脸人和三条腿的意大利男孩。
I mean, it would have been an amusing thing, right? Anyway, he doesn't get it. He still, unfortunately, has not kicked the addiction to girls. So in late 1936, I think it is, he is fined for, again, importuning to 16 year old girls of Victoria. He'd come up to them and said, would you girls like to be the lead actresses in a West End show? See, now he's starting to seem a bit, a bit suspicious again.
是的，为了和那些竞争，你的屁股得挨不少戳。你会去看他们之中的哪一个？我的意思是，实际上我可能会去看牧师。但我挺想看看那个三条腿的意大利男孩。看，我当时在想那个狗脸人。不管怎样，1937年他决定去别的地方碰碰运气。因为在1937年夏天，他被一个假冒船长弗雷德·赖伊邀请加入他在斯格 Ness 度假村的动物园。汤姆，
This is a bit suspicious. Yeah. Now the problem with his showbiz career is obviously, you know, this is always the way with tabloid scandals. People have a short memory and he is competing against quite sexy acts in Blackpool. So by the late 1930s, he's up against acts such as the bearded lady from Russia, the dog faced man and the three legged Italian boy.
你去过斯格 Ness 吗，除了黑潭以外？所以斯格 Ness 在30年代其实更高档，但我现在很喜欢黑潭，不过我觉得斯格 Ness 太糟糕了。我在斯格 Ness 度过了我一生中最糟糕的一晚，我们预订了最贵的一家酒店，我想大概花了12英镑，我一整晚都被隔壁两对正在进行非常充满活力的活动的夫妇吵得睡不着觉，他们大概一点左右停下来，然后三点左右又开始了。好吧。好吧，为他们点赞。我的意思是，是的，但这对我来说可不太妙。不。
Yeah, you'd have to be jabbed a lot in your buttocks to compete with that. Which who are you going to see of all those? I mean actually I'd probably see the rector. But I quite fancy seeing the three legged Italian boy. See I was thinking the dog faced man. But anyway, 1937 he decides to try his luck elsewhere. Because in the summer of 1937, he's invited by a fake captain called Fred Rye to join his menagerie in the resort of Skegness. Tom,
所以，呃，戴维森——好吧，谁知道他会对这种行为作何感想。他可能会去敲门。他会走进去的。嗨，女士们。绝对会。现在，至于你离开西区演出，他有一个非常不同的表演。他将在一个名为“现代狮子坑里的丹尼尔”的节目中表演。这将包括他站在笼子外面发表10分钟的布道。
have you been to Skegness as well as Blackpool? So Skegness was actually posher in the 30s, but now I loved Blackpool, but I thought Skegness was awful. I had the worst night of my life in Skegness we booked ourselves into the most expensive hotel, which I think cost about 12 pounds and I was kept up all night By two couples next door who were having a very energetic time and they stopped around one o'clock and then they started up again about three Okay. Well fair play to them. I mean, yeah, but it wasn't great for me. No.
现在在笼子里，有两只名叫弗雷迪和托托的狮子。然后在布道结束时，他走进笼子花几分钟时间，呃，向狮子们发表讲话。所以在这里你可以看到斯格 Ness 那种比较中产阶级的基调，他不仅屁股挨戳，他在发表布道。所以格调稍微高了一点，对吧？你完全正确。现在的问题是，他害怕动物，他说他对外这些狮子感到紧张，我认为并非不合理，但他同意这么做。现在我猜听这个播客的大多数人都能猜到会发生什么。1937年7月28日，他正在进行晚场演出，现场挤满了度假的家庭。记住，7月28日是旺季的顶峰，他们每人支付了三便士来观看。戴维森发表了他惯常的布道，然后走进笼子向狮子们讲话。狮子通常非常温顺。现在最流行的说法会告诉你，他一不小心踩到了托托的尾巴，但
So, uh, Davidson, well, who knows what he would have made of that behavior. He might've knocked on the door. He would have gone in. Hello ladies. Absolutely would. Now as it is off your part in a West End show, he's got a very different act. He's going to perform in an act called Daniel in a modern lion's den. This would involve him standing outside a cage and delivering a 10 minute sermon.
我进行了一些热情的谷歌搜索，我认为这不是真的，因为我找到了一份目击者的证词。弗雷迪挡了他的路，他试图从弗雷迪和笼子后部之间滑过去。他离托托十万八千里，我确信他根本没有碰到它。不管发生了什么，有什么东西触怒了弗雷迪。从来没有人比罗纳德·布莱思把这一点说得更好了。因此，以几乎难以置信的言辞，诺福克的小牧师和狮子向傻瓜们演绎了古典的基督教殉道。他进行了疯狂而勇敢的搏击，但弗雷迪在目瞪口呆的暴民众目睽睽之下杀了他。实际上发生的是，驯兽师看到这一幕时跑进
Now inside the cage, two lions called Freddie and Toto. And then at the end of the sermon, he gets into the cage to spend a few minutes, um, addressing the lions. And so there you see the, the kind of the more middle class tone of Skegness, that he's not just having his buttocks jabbed, he's delivering a sermon. So it's slightly more elevated, isn't it? You're absolutely right. Now the problem is that he's frightened of animals and he says he's nervous of these
笼子里用棍子打了弗雷迪，把戴维森拖了出来，结果自己昏倒了死前。多米尼克，哈罗德·戴维森对此会感到高兴，不仅因为他被从狮子口中救了出来，还有一个更深层的原因，不是吗，为什么他会高兴被这位特定的驯兽师救下。难以置信的是，驯兽师是一个名叫艾琳的16岁女孩。亲爱的。我对一份工作感兴趣吗？所以戴维森被抬走了。
lions, I think not unreasonably, but he agrees to do it. Now I would suspect that most people listening to this podcast can guess what's going to happen. On the 28th of July 1937, he's giving the evening show and the place is packed with holiday-making families. Remember 28th of July is the peak of the season and they have paid three pence each to attend. Davidson gives his usual sermon and then he goes into the cage to address the lions. The lions are generally very docile. Now the most popular accounts will tell you that he accidentally trod on Toto's tail but
现在他多活了两天，我想是的。报纸声称他在临终前醒来并说：“我上头条了吗？”这显然不是真的。他没这么做。事实上，甚至可能不是狮子杀了他。这就是所有事情中离奇的转折。一个医生不小心给他注射了胰岛素，因为医生以为戴维森有糖尿病但他并没有。
I've done some enthusiastic googling and I think this is not true because I found an eyewitness account. Freddy was in his way and he tried to slip in between him and the back of the cage. He was nowhere near Toto and I'm sure he did not touch her. Whatever happened, something triggered Freddie's ire. And nobody has ever put this better than Ronald Blythe. And thus, in scarcely credible terms, the little clergyman from Norfolk and the lion acted out the classical Christian martyrdom to the fool. He fought wildly, gallantly, but Freddie killed him in full view of a gaping mob. Now, actually what happened is the lion tamer, when she saw this happening, ran into the
而可能正是这个要了他的命。多么悲惨的结局。但这其实并不是故事的结局，因为在黑潭和斯格 Ness，他的传奇仍在流传。所以在斯格 Ness，那个假船长弗雷德·赖伊将其视为一个绝佳的商业机会。他将节目重新命名为“观看残害并导致斯蒂夫克前牧师死亡的真正狮子”，整个夏天场场爆满。弗雷迪和托托。弗雷迪没有因此受到惩罚。
cage and hit Freddie with a stick and dragged Davidson out and dead before fainting herself. And Dominic, Harold Davidson would have been happy about this, not only because he's being rescued from a lion, but there's a further reason, isn't there, why he would have been happy to be rescued by this particular lion tamer. Unbelievably, the lion tamer is a 16 year old girl called Irene. My dear. Could I interest you in a job? So Davidson was carried off.
他们加入了艾琳，艾琳也很快以她自己的方式短暂地成为了一名明星。所以这对艾琳和狮子们来说挺好的，我想。是的。于是牧师确实设法帮助了一个16岁的女孩。他确实帮了。她是唯一一个他真正帮助过的女孩。但在黑潭，他在海滨大道的职位被一个截然不同的人物取代了。我们之前在关于——离奇地——英国法西斯主义的那期节目中曾简短提到过他。是的，这就是巴克上校，一个变性法西斯拳击教练。多米尼克，我们《历史的其余部分》非常喜欢变性法西斯拳击教练，对吧？
Now he lived for another two days, I think it is. The newspapers claimed that he awoke on his deathbed and said, have I made the front page? This is clearly not true. He didn't do this. In fact, it might not even have been the lion that killed him. This is the bizarre twist of all. A doctor accidentally gave him an injection of insulin because he thought Davidson was diabetic but he wasn't.
最初叫莉莉乌斯·尔玛·巴克，后来改名为法勒里·阿克尔-史密斯，接着又用了维克托爵士或巴克上校的名字。他曾担任国家法西斯蒂党（National Fashisti）的军官，化名“人-女人”。是的，而且，呃，培训其成员击剑和拳击。公平地说，他们并不是一个非常严肃的组织，国家法西斯蒂党。不。所以他基本上落得个需要赚钱的下场。正如你所说，接替了牧师的
And it may be that it was that that killed him. So what a sad end. But that's actually not quite the end of the story because in Blackpool and in Skegness his legend lingered. So in Skegness the fake captain Fred Rye saw this as a brilliant commercial opportunity. He rebranded the show as quote see the actual lion that mauled and caused the death of the ex-rector of Stiffke and they had packed houses all summer. Freddie and Toto. Freddie wasn't punished
位置。外面的告示把他描述为世界上第一个做现在著名的变性手术的人，将她的性别从女性变为男性。但同样地，这里带有一种略带窥阴癖的好奇心成分，因为人们来看巴克上校和他或她结婚的女人，他们躺在一张床上，旁边有一只巨大的斑点达尔马提亚狗。他们躺在那里，每天有12个小时被那些俯视他们的人虐待和吐口水。所以事情是这样的，对吧？巴克上校的表演叫《奇异的蜜月》。对吧。
for this. And they were joined by Irene, who also became a star very briefly in her own right. So that was lovely for Irene and for the Lions, I suppose. Yeah. And so the rector did manage to help a 16 year old girl. He did. She was the one girl he really helped. But in Blackpool, his place on the seafront was taken by a very different character. And we have mentioned, I think, briefly before in our episode about, bizarrely, British fascism. Yeah, so this is Colonel Barker, who was a transgender fascist boxing instructor. And Dominic, we do love a transgender fascist boxing instructor on The Rest is History, don't we?
人们会去看这个，但在前面，它是由同一个名为卢克·加农的演出经理组织的的，他曾组织过牧师的木桶秀。在摊位前，加农放了牧师的木桶，而在它后面，似乎是一个裹在殓布下的尸体。所以人们去看巴克上校是带着一种错觉，以为他们同时也在看着斯蒂夫克牧师那具被狮子撕碎的尸体。我的意思是，多米尼克，真是一场奇异的蜜月。这真是一个疯狂的故事。非常感谢你讲这个。我希望大家都能喜欢。
Originally Lilius Irma Barker, then renamed Falery Arkel-Smith and then took the name either Sir Victor or Colonel Barker. And he worked as an officer of the National Fashisti and went under the subricate The Man-Woman. Yes. And, yeah, trained its members in fencing and boxing. They were not a very serious group, I think it's fair to say, the National Fashisti. No. And so he basically ends up needing to make money. And so as you say, takes the rector's
我们下周将带着另一个充满暴力和偶尔羞辱的故事回归，那就是苏格兰女王玛丽的故事。我们下周见。拜拜。拜拜。这个单集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
place. And the notice outside describes him as the first person in the world to have the now famous operation, changing her sex from that of a woman to that of a man. But again, there is this element of slightly prurient curiosity because people come to see Colonel Barker with the woman that he or she has married and they lie on a bed with a huge spotted Dalmatian. They lie there and they have kind of 12 hours a day being abused and spat on by people who are looking down. So here's the thing, right? The Colonel Bach act was called On a Strange Honeymoon. Right.
地方。外面的告示将他描述为世界上第一个接受现今著名的变性手术的人，将性别从女性变为男性。但同样，这里有一种略带窥阴癖的好奇心成分，因为人们来看望巴克上校以及他或她结婚的那个女人，他们躺在一张铺有巨大的斑点大麦町狗图案的床上。他们躺在那里，每天大约有12个小时被那些俯视的人辱骂和吐口水。所以事情是这样的，对吧？巴克上校的表演被称为《奇怪的蜜月》。没错。
People would go to this, but in front it was it was organized by the same impresario called Luke Gannon, who had organized the Rector's Barrel. And in front of the pitch, Gannon put the Rector's Barrel and behind it, what appeared to be a dead body under a shroud. So people were going to see Colonel Barker under the illusion that they were also looking at the corpse, the lion mauled corpse of the rector of Stiffke. I mean, Dominic, a strange honeymoon indeed. It's such a mad story. So thanks so much for that. I hope you've enjoyed that everyone.
人们会去看这个，但在前面它是由同一个名叫卢克·加农的经纪人组织的的，他曾组织过牧师的木桶展。在展位前面，加农放了牧师的木桶，而在它后面，似乎是一具盖着裹尸布的尸体。所以人们去看巴克上校时，还误以为他们同时也在看那具尸体，也就是被狮子撕咬致死的斯蒂夫克牧师的尸体。我的意思是，多米尼克，这确实是一场奇怪的蜜月。这是一个如此疯狂的故事。非常感谢你讲这个故事。希望大家都喜欢。
And we will be back next week with another tale of violence and occasional humiliation, which is that of Mary Queen of Scots. So we will see you next week. Bye bye. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们下周将带着另一个充满暴力和偶尔羞辱的故事回归，那就是苏格兰女王玛丽的故事。所以我们下周见。再见。再见。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。